are you serious oh that was so nice oh
my god that's so nice
[Music]
alright y'all on the show I'm all about
celebrating neighbors doing great things
for one another the idea behind the
campaign is to get to know and maybe
even help someone else in your
neighborhood so I started a hashtag
called hashtag good neighbor challenge
where I asked y'all to send in stories
about how a neighbor has changed her
life for the better my team has gathered
some of the best responses and I haven't
read them yet so give me that wholesome
content let's do it
my friends teenage son has been helping
a homeless vet in his neighborhood and
delivering him food and cider trying to
help him in any way he can Devin
deserves a little recognition not many
of our youth today tend to have the
gumption to reach out in the way this
kid did no one asked him he just saw the
need and decided to help this is the
letter he left for the man as well Oh
totally gonna cry it's fine
you're crying I'm fine good afternoon we
packed you a lunch and cider and left
you a pizza for dinner to help where we
can we do see you and we do care about
you oh Michael when you are finished
with the food and cider please leave the
lunch bag sorry the lunch bag trash and
bottle out where we can refill it we
hope this helps and we'll continue to
search for resources to get you on your
feet also this is from a teenage boy
also we would like to know if you need a
coat gloves hat it is getting cold out
oh I walk by you every morning we are
sorry you're going through this and
we'll continue to try to make it easier
okay in any way we can my mom will make
you a warm plate in the evenings when
she is home and I can put something
together when she has not keep her head
up thank you for your service Devin are
you serious oh that was so nice oh my
god that's so nice I'm also gonna show
this letter to my kids and be like look
it's so nice it's kind he didn't even
know
much probably is just like look I'll
just sit these are little things that
you don't think are gonna matter but
they're big things for people you know
jesse has been an amazing neighbor for
12 years she leaves soup on my doorstep
and cookies in my mailbox but three
years ago something really special
happened I unexpectedly became a foster
parent my foster son identified Jesse as
grandma within a few months of being in
my home Jesse welcomed the role she
helps with getting him to therapy and
watched him while I ran to the grocery
store or walked the dog I adopted my son
and Jesse adopted us both when I lost my
job and needed to sell my home my son
and I lived with Jesse for a month while
we wrapped up the adoption process and
transitioned into our new home we will
remain family from this point forward I
can't imagine life without this amazing
woman look at that that's so kind si
good neighbor campaign I'm in then this
feel good you know you're crying for
good reason and not a really sad one
where you think oh god everything's
going to that word I have a neighbor
that is basically the good neighborhood
grandma she has retired so she gets my
daughter on the bus for me every day
that's adorable
she invites the neighborhood kids over
to help her decorate for holidays and
buys them pizza she has neighborhood
parties to make sure everyone gets to
know each other she watches our dog we
go out of town she isn't only an amazing
neighbor to us but the entire
neighborhood knows miss Pam and how
awesome she is he does all these things
and if we offered to repay her she scoff
friends help friends there is no need
for payback
oh we move last year but for 16 years I
had the best neighbor ever we helped
each other raise our kids and shared
every aspect of life she was more like a
sister life has been one upset after
another for the last nine years for me
from a house fire losing both oh gosh my
parents tragically losing my father and
loss suddenly to cancer and everything
in between good gosh she has been my
rock she has cried with me held me while
I cried prayed with me and for me and
always has an encouraging word I know I
can call her day or night and even still
she is right here we only moved a couple
miles up the road Sheila Road has been
my special these are all Mike's fat and
sweet Sheila Road has been my special
blessing from God and I love her
very much she has truly the best
neighbor ever you guys I love y'all my
neighbor sat throughout the night with
my mom and I as my mom was oh my gosh my
neighbor sat throughout the night with
my mom and I as my mom was dying last
month I would call her at 2:00 a.m. and
she'd come right over and stay until
4:00 with me when it was just too much
she's truly the greatest really nice and
also really sad I'm sorry you ever you
know like you grew up and people are
like God doesn't give you anything you
can't handle I swear and like my worst
moments I feel like yelled at God and
I'm like well I can't handle this too
much I mean I guess it's true but whoa
okay so that was incredible I love those
stories if you want to share your story
with me please do use the hashtag
hashtag good neighbor challenge on
Facebook and Instagram and we might use
it on the show or here on the Internet
can't wait to read them y'all keep
spreading kindness I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this